[Music]
welcome about me on a Batman I'm Kevin
Smith
okay obviously not the best way to do
this but I'm in Vancouver finishing up
my episode of Supergirl so I got two
days left so I'm not in the fact cave
I'm in the temporary Vancouver Fred cave
West and but I got to talk about Doctor
Strange son sling ring and [ __ ] before
we get there though
we got a sponsor which is always a
wondrous thing here the sponsor folks me
andhis me undies got me undies as Popeye
used to say I could go Giga me undies
dot-com and you sign up for this service
me and ease comm
slash fat man and you'll get a discount
uh you get underwear once a month I just
sent it to your [ __ ] house you don't
have to go out to the store to get any
more [ __ ] the tyranny of shopping for
men's Underpants or women's Underpants
they do both man [ __ ] leaving the house
to go get underwear they'll send you
underwear and look at this [ __ ] they'll
send you underwear with Dinosaurs on
look at that that's the closest I want
to be to a man's crotch in underwear
sperm
maybe I'm curious but whatever look at
this send it right to your house look at
this that's not good enough you like
dinosaurs one of my child Donuts son
donuts look at this panty man doughnuts
and it's not all these like where they
boxers could be briefs could be briefs
like this look look at this [ __ ] and
look you're like oh great that's sleek
but look back girl purple inside me and
these that comes service I believe in
mangas they sent me uh appearance number
one they fit so I was a big plus in my
world number two I had variety suddenly
I had different colors and stuff I was
wearing this [ __ ] my wife was like you
look like you're trying to fit in and be
young and I am me undies calm slash fat
man they'll give you a fat 20% discount
I think it is for initially joining
underwears fantastic comfy as hell
breathes and there's a variety man I
used to be a one underwear color man
just like majoras look like my
closets with with nothing but the same
color underwear now a rainbow of
underwear all over my face neck and
chest as for you
bear lovers out there so me undies calm
go there right now man support fat man
I'm Batman
okay let's talk about something even
more magical than underwears that arrive
at your door once a month and I'm
talking about the strange son dr.
strange man this was a movie I was very
excited to see because I've loved dr.
strange going way back i put dr. strange
into my daredevil run the one I did with
joke aside a guardian devil back in the
day we had a scene where he had to go to
Bleecker Street to the sanctum sanctorum
and [ __ ] like that so this movie man
they had to just say a few things I'm in
the bag for these movies let's be honest
I'm not sitting here going critically
thinking dr. strange although it's a
wonderful movie I'm in the bag for these
men the moment you start saying like
sanctum sanctorum when you start saying
I of agamotto when you start saying but
I've always thought was Dormammu and now
we know is Dormammu I'm going to keep
saying Dormammu cos bucket I like it
that way dr. strange man came to life
the creation of Steve Ditko and later on
Stan Lee brought to life writ large by
scott derrickson on the big screen if
you've never heard the episode of
smoothie makers podcast that I did with
Scott Derrickson
sit down let's do we did a few years
back long before I think strange was in
his future I don't know maybe was just
the beginning really sweet guy talented
dude talent as [ __ ] as we saw from
strangest weekend man because he brought
Ditko panels to life we went to the Dark
Dimension that [ __ ] looked like dick go
drawings writ large man the slang ring
was a new addition but I thought that
was cool right away I was just like woo
they should always other but come on man
the Cape as Groot
you know what I'm saying like the fun
object in the movie that's there's a
fact that helps one of the main
characters some people would say it's
kind of like more like his [ __ ] Iron
Man suit don't you think dude yes I
guess but it had its own life it was
very Beauty and the Beast that way and
stuff but I loved that addition of a
cloak of levitation I'm a big Doctor
Strange fan and they had every element
that
I want to see it play in this movie
let's let's take it from the top
Benedict Cumberbatch did a wonderful job
we all knew he would the moment they
cast him strange and he brought that
character to life turned him sexy turned
strange into a sex character movie
opened huge this weekend so a lot of
people like dude before didn't know who
dr. strange was like what's that now
they know they like oh that's Benedict
come about this Sherlock Sherlock in the
Marvel Universe some people I've read
reviews with the likes movies just like
Iron Man it's just like another origin
movie for Marvel that's what I want out
of these movies I don't want it to be
different like I want my comic book
movies as they come to the big screen at
least the first one to play like an
origin story and it needs to have all
the familiar beats and stuff and not yes
this one was familiar in as much as Tony
Stark was kind of cocky and then he's
knocked down the sides and he decided to
come here
same thing here hey man that's the story
in a lot of [ __ ] stories but that's
what I want my combo Gorgias they did it
justice and whatnot they brought in
people like the night nurse then calling
night nurse and ship she's one of the
three night nurses and stuff Christine
they brought in more - come on dude what
up but made them buddies so like you
know they kind of come up together a
little bit and they didn't make him just
like evil like in spoilers in the end
you know tag they kind of set it up for
him going there's too many saucers in
this world so he's gonna be like a
[ __ ] saucer or killer and [ __ ] but
they be guests are today's pals Wong
also started as a master in the comics
generally he's just kind of like his
Alfred his assistant to Doctor Strange
in the sanctum sanctorum but there he is
as a master in this movie the ancient
one is brilliantly played by Tilda
Swinton
you know she's wonderful everything she
does fantastic man she's so smart she's
so theory all the things they write
about her and stuff I met her once man
is crazy I met her at a film festival
and [ __ ] in real life you think like she
has powers on-screen meet her in real
life son and she laughed as something I
said
try making till the sweat and let little
your heart will actually project out
advisor getting punched and watching
your [ __ ] leave just like they did in
this movie I love that sequence I loved
everything about this flick I was so in
the bagman you got to remember when they
mentioned I think it was in like was it
captain
the civil and not not civil or Captain
America Winter Soldier movie when they
even mentioned like they it's going to
pick people out all over the world like
this [ __ ] this man they were
like Stephen strange there's like so I
was in the bag for this flick and Scott
Derrickson and the good folks at Marvel
Kevin Feige will not did not disappoint
they did not drop the ball by any
stretch of the imagination is perfect
strange doctor strange origin movie for
me and based on the box office seems
like it might be for a lot of people as
well let's go through it shall we as we
saw in the trailer Stephen strange
brilliant a surgeon loses his spoiler is
gonna blot spoilers and this loses his
ability to to work with his hands loses
his hand jobs if you will no more hand
jobs because he gets in a bad accident
pretty harrowing accident as shot
incredibly well and and then you know
can't do the thing he was made to do
that's what I like about this movie a
lot there you know the less simple
lesson of it's not about you [ __ ]
rings resonates throughout the flick
strange wants to get himself back you
know he's a guy who am i without the guy
who can't operate and stuff and and I
you know I thought about this as I was
watching the movie I was like alright
you get in a car wreck and you can't do
the thing that you're known to do which
for me would be using my [ __ ] mouth
some people be like Phil make him like
know just being oral and whatnot with
all these podcast announced agents being
who would you be at that point I'd be
quiet so you know I put yourself at
Stephen strange of shoes that's tough
what are you can do for the rest of your
life is like a hockey player has to hang
up the skates like hey man this is what
you want to do your whole life now you
can never do anymore what do you do for
the rest of your life
strange can't accept that he wants to
heal himself and he meets a dude from
Law & Order from one of the better
seasons of Law & Order who's just like
Benjamin bear who's like hey man like
yeah you can you can heal yourself I did
it I visited this place and they in so
strange goes looking for it and finds it
where it finds him as so often is the
case in movies like this particularly
and there he meets the Masters in the
ancient one and learns that yes you can
save people with more than just you know
these these
hands you know check it out dude we can
take you to the astral plane and they do
this movie [ __ ] so [ __ ] with
dimensional doors and [ __ ] it's like
Inception on coke in many places like
when the world starts folding in on
itself oftentimes like you know the
[ __ ] Sorcerer's Supremes will like
[ __ ] bad and change an environment
just to trip a [ __ ]
not even to kill him and [ __ ] like that
blissful look at you know is it wonder
sheer wonder visually [ __ ]
interesting his [ __ ] but for me just
hearing certain things like Dormammu
hearing the sanctum sanctorum seeing the
address plate for the New York [ __ ]
house for the sanctum like hearing
somebody [ __ ] say I of agamotto and
it was like in a mainstream movie [ __ ]
like this I was like so [ __ ] stiff I
love Rachel McAdams and you know she's
wonderful in the flick didn't give her a
bunch to do but I like their scenes
together her and Benjamin Benedict
Cumberbatch
we're wonderful more of that in the
future are sitting there going are going
to call our night nurse and they didn't
seems like they're saving reserving that
for Claire temple over in the TV
universe or something like that but
never rule it out this was a pure origin
story that wraps up in I thought a kind
of cool third act like you know strange
like spoilers strange sacrificing
himself like Christ like if you will
over and over again to dorm I'm gonna
say door mama that's not stupid Dormammu
my [ __ ] like just Dormammu oh I love
that sequence and they've killed them a
thousand different ways and stuck in it
in a time loop and [ __ ] like that
I love the representation of spell
casting in this look that spell casting
in this flick so did it for me [ __ ] like
that I love I wish we lived in a world
of [ __ ] like that I do that in
traffic all the time
wish I could [ __ ] make little hexes
and defensive spells and [ __ ] like that
really propels and spells like speed the
[ __ ] up you call that driving I got you
what do you have nowhere to be I'm in
Vancouver obviously so I loved Scott's
representation of that with the spells
Casillas played by Mads Mikkelsen I
thought was cool and had that one for
funny beat you see in the trailer where
he's like strange doctor mr. strange mr.
dr. strange he goes it's just strange
you as well it's up to you or whatever
[ __ ] like that he's funny but mostly but
I thought it's um I saw some people
didn't like his eyes other look cool so
every time they went to a close-up you
could see the dark dimension in the eyes
and she had I thought that kind of [ __ ]
look badass but it's uh watching
characters that I've always loved come
to life yet again we've seen that time
and time again but didn't stunts justice
this [ __ ] cloak of levitation
that whole sequence I was rolling a tear
man I was just like ah it's crazy we
live in a world where doctor strains is
a mainstream movie man where my mom was
like Oh tiger I went to see dr. strange
like and not like I went to see dr.
kaylis who told me that my adjective
blah blah blah she went to see a good
doctor man in a movie theater and [ __ ]
like that and had a good ass tongue so I
love this movie
the let's see what else can we talk
about that I [ __ ] love here before me
let's just look up online before we get
out of here so in case I don't miss
anybody not doom justice or anything
like that talked about Tilda Swinton man
talk chu ëtil alleging for I think I'm
pronouncing that right I thought was
about a noble Mordo but he boil boy
looks like he's going to be well we know
he's going to spoilers we know mortos
bad guy and sub paramour doe but in this
instance we're kind of using an origin
story to separate them so I what I like
about is just like iske caelius his
mission isn't like I just want to be a
prick he believes he's doing justice so
this is like no we Rose if we could put
ourselves into the Dark Dimension we'll
all live forever and [ __ ] like that
the ancient ones steal and [ __ ] power
from the Dark Dimension anyway it's a
whole [ __ ] car house of cards ally
strange so the notion that Mordo is is
also going to be like hey i'm not trying
to be a prick but like they're way too
many [ __ ] saucers than too many
saucers and start to
in [ __ ] out or at least taking
away their magical abilities I'm all for
that and I also want more Dormammu and I
hope every movie has door mu idolater I
don't give a [ __ ] if every Doctor
Strange movie ended with the same third
act with him facing off against Dormammu
and I'm going to keep saying door mooing
and I know I've been educated otherwise
but [ __ ] it I love that aspect of man
like you know so you want to talk about
self-sacrifice generally the third act
of these movies is like let's you know
punch a [ __ ] giant donut hole in the
sky and fight it together let's fight
the CG menace and this true also it was
a CG Menace Dormammu but in the door in
the in the I guess boy him rip myself to
a corner but what I liked was instead of
punching his way out of it and stuff it
was he was prepared to spoilers he's
prepared to live in this time loop
forever trapped with Dormammu so he
can't bring the you know the Dark
Dimension to earth or put earth into the
Dark Dimension although that was some
clever [ __ ] man
I enjoyed the [ __ ] out of this picture I
saw it 40x
do you ever see a 40x movie Jesus Christ
this guy sound like commercial begging
no stalking for DX but a good idea is a
good idea here I'm just the same way I
got no stock and [ __ ] Doctor Strange
but like Here I am
Oh [ __ ] sanctum sanctorum o of my
face neck and chest taking it from the
[ __ ] one-eyed I love my art I've gone
too far as much as a strange rock seeing
in 40x if you've never seen a movie in
40x it's like you know when you go to
like Universal and like the Shrek Rider
The Simpsons Ride motion ride it's like
that for the whole [ __ ] move even for
simple [ __ ] like when the Marvel logo is
moving your chair is moving and [ __ ]
like that
they blow air at you in water and
there's it's snowed in my theatre when
he went to Nepal like come on man that's
[ __ ] crazy I think they got theaters
in New York and Illinois and Chicago of
course and Los Angeles I think there's a
few ever in other countries as well
those are three I know of in the States
if you can see it if you see any movie
in in 40x temper Kevin Smith movie weird
like nothing ever happens so all those
weird effects and [ __ ] like if they're
tires screeching you smell / Robert
[ __ ] up his [ __ ] up a wonderful so
for strange when you were tripping
through all as always your chairs like
them and it's fluid you know it's not
like kink you're getting good good it's
pretty it's good [ __ ] time so I
enjoyed the [ __ ] out of that I got no
stock in that company but if you can
[ __ ] see a movie particularly this
movie Doctor Strange and 40x see it then
my other caveat to that review is
there's not for everybody
some people like look you fat [ __ ] I
enjoy life without the help of [ __ ]
anything else I get high on life I'm
talking to the other people out there
I'm good for you people I wish I could
be like you admire you greatly but for
those of us who are degenerate stoners
get baked and see this movie oh my god
it's it's phenomenal man I was just
baked as the days long it was just like
number one everything's better big
number two this movie as you go through
dimensional realms man the multiverse
the Marvel multiverse not going to say
is making it better just going to say
just gonna say it's definitely worth
your time if you're inclined in that
direction alright so there it is man my
review of dr. traci scott derrickson
knocks it out the [ __ ] Park I thought
he was fantastic Benedict Wan we didn't
talk about him as Wong how ironic he was
funny as [ __ ] of course as the movies
moment with that bones and and the
Beyonce joke um definitely worth your
time and Marvel does it again [ __ ]
they could do nothing wrong that's what
I think anyway there it is that's my
review for fat man Batman Kevin Smith
man what the [ __ ] you waiting for
go see Doctor Strange hey boys and girls
it's me Mark Barnard in one of your fat
men on the Batman but and today is gonna
be fat man on strange man I saw Doctor
Strange again I had seen it before I saw
it at the premiere surrounded by people
who are far far thinner than I am and
miserable for it but I'm pretty sure
Kevin will either have already given you
his thoughts on the Doctor Strange or
will follow me either way you're being
sandwiched by awesome so uh so yes the
Doctor Strange I like this movie I don't
love this movie but I like it a lot and
actually the second viewing sort of
helped that for me
there are things that I like quite a bit
about it there are a couple things that
I'm a little ambivalent towards but
we'll get there we'll start with the
good because why not lead with the good
Benedict Cumberbatch kills it he has
just the right amount of kind of
imperious haughtiness that of like a
mid-level Imperial officer on a Death
Star or some other sort of evil
spaceship um so he's kind of humbling as
the movie goes on registers I think I
wondered why he didn't just use his
natural British accent like there's no
reason why Doctor Strange has to be
American he has to live in New York
that's for damn sure
but given that everybody else he has
accents and are killing it with those
accents
every now and again you'll just hear the
slip and I kept wondering why not just
let it be British that's totally fine
that'll work the rest of the cast is
great like I will I will watch chiwetel
ejiofor do almost anything in almost
anything
I watched him in kinky boots where he
wore kinky boots
I watched him in serenity I watched him
an Inside Man I will see that dude do
almost anything Mads Mikkelsen
is great I love him as a villain there's
there's a real sort of emotion to that
and you get why he is the way he is I
feel like the special effects in this
movie are about as good as I've seen in
any Marvel movie if not better like I
feel like they spent the money in a way
that they haven't before and all the
kind of magic II Inception II like
everything's floating in himself and
everybody's running on ceilings and
walls and all that [ __ ] works really
really well I do feel that they sort of
indulge themselves one too many times
with that like once twice I get it it's
cool it's super cool there's the third
sequence where it just got a little bit
we're doing it for its own sake like
look what we can do you guys we're gonna
do it a lot I didn't need them to be
doing it a lot but that final set piece
that whole like backwards time
rebuilding that cityscape in Hong Kong
and then fighting inside a backwards
unfolding city like that's I've never
seen that before and that's astounding
and I feel like the it's it's an origin
story for sure and it does all the
things that an origin story does
and it dispatches with enough of it the
stuff that you have to have it does
pretty gracefully the stuff that's kind
of new and interesting it gives some
time to breathe the one the one thing
story wise that I was a little that I
wanted more of was like they set up this
whole idea in the beginning of the movie
that dr. strange is an [ __ ] and he's
an [ __ ] because he's so self-centered
and so egotistical and everybody tells
him that and everybody tells him that
that's his problem
and it's abundantly clear that the
reason why he and dr. Christine Palmer's
relationship played by Rachel McAdams
didn't work out was because he's an
[ __ ] which you totally buy the thing
that I wanted to see by the end of that
movie was the scene in which she sees
him be self-sacrificing she sees him be
the man that she always hoped it would
be
they hoped he would be I mean you get
him like you know in all of his magic
doctor robes showing up in the hospital
and doing all kinds of cool stuff and
natural projecting and saving other
people's lives and you get all that
stuff but I wanted the giant grand like
she's be holding him be the better man
for everybody she's watching him
sacrifice himself and his sacrifice at
the end of the movie where he's willing
to spoilers I'm assuming you guys have
seen this by now but or he is willing to
subject himself to an eternity of
torture to keep Dormammu in that same
temporal prison with him it's a great
sacrifice and it works really well and I
like that I like that he's losing but
he's willing to lose forever to save
everybody else that's awesome I wish
somebody else saw that I wish somebody
else could know that I wish somebody
else felt his pain for having done that
so that people could know that he was
the man he could be that he's living up
to his potential for all those reasons
like I think it's a really really solid
movie I feel like the whole ancient one
business which we've talked about before
like I've written on it it's out there
in the world the idea that the ancient
one written has a Tibetan man in the
comics is now played by Tilda Swinton
who is an amazing actress like nobody
does sort of ethereal other nests like
quite like she does I feel like the
ancient one is a
it's one of those like land mines where
there's almost no graceful way to step
around it you're kind of going to get
blown up and caught in the blast if you
do the ante one because either you
recast it with somebody who is not Asian
to alleviate the weird like Orientalism
of the of the ancient one but then
you're white washing away a roll that
could have gone to an Asian actor an
amazing Asian actor and a good writer
can absolutely right a great version of
the ancient one but if you cast an Asian
actor then you have all of that like you
know ancient Chinese secret fortune
cookie storytelling like all of those
horrible things that had been be acted
upon Asian actors doing that kind of
mysticism in Hollywood for decades but I
feel like there was a way to do it even
there's a way to do it so that you get
to keep Tilda Swinton and you get to
keep all of that stuff and I feel like
they kind of toad up against this line
but didn't cross it but the idea that
maybe the ancient one reincarnates every
hundred years maybe there's a world in
which there have been a dozen ancient
ones and each ancient one is from a
different place is a different sex is a
different race and so this one happens
to be Tilda Swinton the last one could
have been you know James hung the next
one could be Dakota Fanning like it kind
of doesn't matter like I feel like
there's a way to make that character
just encode it Doctor Who style so that
it's the same person but it's a
different person and each person brings
with them something else and so that way
you get you cake and you get to eat it
too they didn't do that and that's fine
like every every filmmaker makes his own
choices and they live or die by them and
I feel like ultimately Scott Derrickson
made the choices he believed in and I
feel like the movie by and large lives
by those choices it doesn't die by very
much of anything I do wish that you know
Rachel McAdams has character had a
little bit more to do than to be the
impetus for Stephen strange to to to
remember the person who's supposed to be
that kind of stock female role of by the
end of the third act I think I'm a
second act being the nudge to make the
hero remember you're supposed to be
heroic um but I think like the movie
does quite a lot well it is not my
favorite Marvel movie it is it is
definitely in the in the upper tier of
them it's in like the top third
it is not as I like to call it one of
the two Marvel movies that have twos in
the title kind of that don't really work
very well being Iron Man two and Thor to
the dark world neither of them seem to
be overwhelmingly inspired films Iron
Man 2 was basically Iron Man 1 with
birds and then Thor the dark world
suffers from too much Loki and not
enough whatever that other guy's name
was so you don't actually have an
antagonist for Thor you just kind of
have this weird tour through
metaphysical setting up the ether is all
that movie does and it doesn't even do
it very well but you know I and this
movie isn't for me quite as fun as say
guardians are ant-man the other two like
just out of left field standalone Marvel
movies both of those sort of brought a
different flavor to it and this
absolutely I mean magic and mysticism
and fantasy is all its own flavor that's
great but I kind of just I wish that it
hadn't been quite so like like hero's
quest II and a little bit more lived in
like ant-man has some of those bits but
it's a heist movie at its heart like
guardians has some of those bits but
it's a space opera at its heart like
this this feels a little bit more
traditional heroic journey and that's
fine that's fine you know I again cannot
fault in movie for what it is
and I cannot pretend to critique the
movie that I want to exist how I'll do
it all the time you know I will I'm the
worst that way but hey listen you heard
what I thought you will or have already
heard Kevin thought go see it tell us
what you thought you know find us on the
Internet's you know where we are on at
mark barnard on twitter kevin is apt
that Kevin Smith from the mckibben
Smith's you know leave the comments
below down there on the YouTube page and
just let us know what you thought
because I mean I think it's it's it's
always interesting when Marvel stretches
their wings a little bit when they try
and do something that they are not known
for doing and there's always some
tension on the edges but ultimately I
think it's good for both Marvel it's
good for the audience you know and it's
good for it's good for comics man it's
good for the [ __ ] that we love that it
exists in such a grand fashion
so yeah listen and before I go before I
go I want to tell you a little bit about
my favorite new thing and you know you
can't see me kind of dancing in my seat
because I'm so happy about it but me
undies calm is a sponsor now for the for
the fancy show for the fancy phantom end
of the Batman's and if you I mean they
say clothes make the man but you feel
like a goddamn superhero wearing these
Underpants because nothing has quite
cradled you the way these Underpants
will cradle you I'm just saying it's
it's kind of like your favorite person's
hands just cupping your butt all day
long and it's the best so you should go
to biondi's comm go to Mandy's come
slash fat man into the fat man code and
you get 20% off your first order you
don't like them send them back they will
refund you and let you keep that first
pair of Underpants
so listen give it a try you will kind of
fall in love with them in a big bad way
they're kind of falling in love that you
might need to talk to somebody about but
it's a matter cause it feels so good so
yes me a nice calm slush fat man give it
a go famine on Batman and Bev Abu blah
blah blah this is Mark Barnard and
signing off y'all be good take it easy
[Music]
you